through the system myself and I've done
time and I've seen you know for my
experience I'm not making excuses for
what I did because I you know paid the
price but uh I've had multiple duis and
I've had felony charges snotty nothing
like see it's all like nothing that
would get me in trouble you know no no
moral crimes of moral turpitude type
thing but now I'm curious if you're if
you're open to telling me like what what
goes on when you end up with the DUI
like is it do you know you shouldn't be
driving but something just takes over
is it circumstance what happens what do
you mean what causes me to have the DUI
yeah like in other words something makes
you say I'm gonna get behind the wheel
even though I shouldn't right well I'm
blacked out at that point I have I'm not
in control at all I say man on autopilot
I say I mean stuff like that only
happens when I'm by myself drinking and
black you know this I had I've had four
duis and I had to have a breathalyzer
for three years in my vehicle Wow seven
seventy bucks a month for three years
and are you doing okay how are you doing
now I'm doing better I've went on I I
kind of go on binges there's been times
where I you know stay drunk for days and
there's times where I don't drink for a
couple weeks or a couple months and then
it's just a form of self-medication
because I'm I'm bipolar
but with mild psychotic features and I
have PTSD I was in the military plus I
the ptsds from the incarceration but and
are you getting uh are you getting the
the treatment you need for for that no
not not really because it's really it's
a this is a major problem that a lot of
people have is especially veterans who
are relying on VA health care if you I
mean I work eight two four eight two
five and so they closed it for 4:30 or
5:00 so it's it's almost impossible for
me to get to the to the see the
counselor to the meeting so it's not a
financial thing
it's not a financial thing it's just a
life is busy thing well it's a financial
thing because if I had better healthcare
I could I'd have access to to doctors to
care when I when I need it afterwards
because I can't I mean I can ask it off
I can ask to leave early but it just
creates problems when I do that I mean
oh right yeah that's my time off here
then not paid I mean the adoption right
well the option is I could go to rehab
but I don't it's more of a impulsive
thing it's like I don't I mean I've gone
through the detoxes before but I mean I
can stop and not drink for a couple days
I'm not gonna you know I'm not going to
have a seizure it's not that bad
I've had I've been close to that in the
past and different periods but but if I
were to go in to read that rehab I would
have to I would lose my job probably I
would probably lose my home right
because I would I mean it's like that
and that's a big problem for a lot of
people especially the underclass and so
but eventually I mean first for some
people who are more extreme with other
things that will catch up with them and
ever we always so well we got to figure
it out as also because when you're when
you get out there and when you and
you're driving and and you're
intoxicated you're putting other
people's lives at risk
oh absolutely but I don't I don't see
that ever happening again after all the
crap I've gone through with it
I mean there's these dainty things if I
know I'm good I mean I take precautions
these days it's just in the day in the
age of uber it's it's just senseless
yeah absolutely all right hear from you
and you know hope you keep yeah we want
you